Hello, listener.
My name is Jason.
I am one-third of the machine you have tuned in to listen to.
Speaking of machinery, those two tools are on their way in.
Sit tight, turn it up.
Here it comes.
Welcome to Smartless.
Hey, guys, guess what?
What is it, John?
There's our live episodes out now on YouTube with Jonah Hill from the Avalon.
Our live episode.
How can people find it?
It's at YouTube slash Smart.
Is that right?
Say it again?
I wasn't writing.
Yeah, it's at YouTube.com slash smartless.
And you can watch it,
and it's a live show at the Avalon with Joan Hill.
So you can see us instead of heroes.
This is correct.
All right, well, thanks for the housekeeping there.
Anyway, let's get back to things.
By the way, what do you guys think of my shirt?
I do notice you're wearing a NASA hat today.
Are you feeling excited about the Artemis, too?
Isn't that wild?
Let's talk about that.
Why is everybody freaking out about that?
Because we've been going like traveling to Mars and shit.
No.
Well, but like we did the moon loop, did the moon landing is 68, 9, something like that?
Yeah, 69, yeah.
They're not even landing on the moon.
They're just going to kind of do a little lasso around it.
They're pussies.
But it's just like, why is everyone like, oh, God, it.
No, I think it's amazing what they're doing.
They're slingshitting it, by the way.
I'm just saying, like, help me understand.
Yeah, no, well, because it's the farthest anybody's,
been ever. Is that right?
I think so. I think it's the far
humans, yeah, from Earth. From Earth, yeah.
Because we're traveling around the backside
of it as opposed to landing on the front of it?
That's correct, yeah. Well, that seems like
they're reaching for a record there, you know?
That's like not going to Jason's house, but just stopping
at Will's house. Yeah, I mean, I just
don't know if that's something... It feels like
the equivalent of Oscar Bate.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, what if they did? How about this? What if they do
that one loop, right?
So they qualify for Frist.
And then when they come back around,
fucking land the thing.
Like, you know,
and drive the buggy around again
and hit another golf shot,
that'll be really sensational.
I'm going to try to get you an email address
so you can send this in.
I'm sure they're looking for ideas over there.
Of course.
Wait, Jay, but I think they're,
I think the idea is to collect more information
so that the next one they can land on the moon.
Again.
Yeah, I think.
What about if they put, like,
build like a little treehouse on it or something like that.
Well, I think they're talking about that.
Yeah, they're talking about like colonizing a little tiny thing
so that you can launch from there to Mars.
Would you ever sign, if you, would you ever do one of these rocket launches?
Like, what's his face that Amazon did?
Jack Bezos.
Right, he sent some people up.
Would you ever do that?
I would, yeah.
Really?
Yeah, absolutely.
Wouldn't you?
Willie?
I think I probably would.
I mean, wouldn't that be cool?
You wouldn't push out like a day before and go, well, hang on.
I wouldn't pay for it.
I never pay for it.
Right.
Yeah, well, nobody paid for it.
Did those people pay for it?
Only in dignity.
The Bezos people, they pay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like $250,000 or some shit to go.
Really?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's crazy money.
You can go up and leave the atmosphere and come back down.
Yeah, to feel weightlessness.
Wouldn't that be fun?
Well, I'd love to get Neil DeGrasse-Tie.
Jason back on just to finish up that answer he was forming for me.
I know.
I think it's all pretty cool.
I mean, I'm not obsessed with it, but I think it's pretty damn cool.
Yeah, they had some toilet problems on the Artemis, too.
Did you read that?
Yeah.
Yes.
I had a toilet problem this morning.
Let me tell you this.
Jason, you know, Jason, you could never go because they don't have a shower.
tremendous toilet.
Because they don't have a shower next to the toilet up there, so you never be able to go.
You can't shower immediately out.
after a BN?
No.
Well, I'm out.
Yeah, of course you're out.
I got to feel fresh, you guys.
As I explore the universe.
Can you use a flushable wipe up there since there's no flushing?
I bet.
I'm sorry.
Wait, you know what else?
But I've been watching that new documentary, the Bob Lazar S4 thing.
No, what's that?
I like a new documentary.
Yeah, so you've got to see Bob Lazar.
You know Bob Lazar, who worked at Area 51 and has been talking about it for decades.
And nobody believes him, and he's like, I keep, he has drawings, he has memories, it's, it's fascinating.
And he, he, he, he, uh, it's called, uh, it's called, never mind, we look up at, it's called
S4, the Bob Lizarre story. Okay. So, oh, go ahead, sorry. No, keep going, I'm saying so.
Yeah, so, so, so the, um, he went into, as, he used to work there. I know, I'm hurrying.
I know, I'm hurrying. He went into, he used to work there. And there was this long hanger of, of, of, like, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of,
parts of alien spacecraft.
I like getting involved.
I mean, I'm sweating.
Literally sweating.
So there's a long hanger.
Yeah, no, there's a hanger with different sections,
and each section has different parts of alien spacecraft
that they've collected over the years.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah, that doc we were talking about,
I don't know if we were talking about it,
on the podcast or away, but the age of disclosure,
you know, James Clapper and John Brennan,
they're talking about, like, yeah,
yeah, we have been doing crash site recovery
for years.
Yes, forever.
And Bob Lazar has been talking about it
way before they have.
And Doni said, well, to myself, self,
why don't we know about all this
in a much more mainstream way?
And the answer is, is simply,
it would be too unsettling and disruptive to society.
I think now it's slowly coming.
I think now it's slowly coming out
because I think we can handle it now.
Do you think we're helping
by having little conversations like this on a podcast?
Absolutely.
This is having a major impact.
Conditioning the public?
This is,
This is helping turn the tide for sure.
Or not for us holding their hand
into something unsettling.
People would be shocked.
Us just having this sort of really loose
anecdotal conversation where we can't even remember
the names of the goddamn documentary
is having a real effect.
And not even know that mission of Artemis too.
Yeah, exactly.
Not even knowing.
Well, you know, listen,
this is all good stuff.
Talk about a segue.
I think this fella,
might have a nice perspective for us on this.
Now, this is today, it brings us a voice of the current,
the relevant, the forward and the fresh.
Okay, this comedian, artist, and media entrepreneur
was born in Egypt, lives in New York,
spends his time delivering us one of the most viewed
and talked about online interview shows around.
His work has gathered billions of views,
achieved acclaim from New York Times,
GQ, New Yorker, Vanity,
as well as receiving multiple Webby nominations.
Please welcome.
Not a fancy schmancy triple A-list celebrity type, you two.
No, no, this is a man of the people, a voice of the Hattinan,
a guy with some helpful hot takes, the host of Subway takes, Mr. Karim Rama.
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Aliens are real.
The truth is out there.
Right?
Do you think there's a chance this is a real thing?
that we're going to the moon?
No.
That we're going to do a lap.
That part's true.
We're in mid-lap right now.
No, I mean that like we're go, like that the rocket's even in space.
Who knows if it's even in space?
Oh.
Oh, let's go all the way back there.
What do you mean?
What are you saying?
Are you, do you think that maybe we filmed the landing on the moon in a soundstage?
Look, I am not a scientist, but I saw that the curve of the rocket, like when it was
going in space kind of looks like it's not going up,
it's going into the ocean.
I'm just saying, I saw one video about this.
If the arc continued, it's going to plummet.
It's just going to go into those?
No, no, no.
A short social media video is all I need.
I think that arc is to offset the rotation of the Earth.
That's right.
It looks like it's going straight up, but it's not.
It's going against the curve of the Earth.
But the Earth is flat, so that makes no sense.
Okay, thank you for joining us.
I'll see you guys there.
No, I don't believe at disclaimer.
I don't believe any of that.
I believe in the real world is round.
So you don't think there's any possibility
that there is life outside Earth
or sort of intelligent beings
and that perhaps they may have crashed on this Earth
a couple of times and that the government is aware.
No, I fully believe that.
I've had extraterrestrial experience.
I'm surprised none of you guys have.
Welcome back to our episode.
Oh, Thomas.
No.
You guys haven't had extraterrestrial experiences?
Well, I did mention...
No comment.
Let's hear what...
Tell us yours first.
Yeah.
Now, see, now it sounds fake, but I saw an alien in the bushes.
Mm-hmm.
But I was a kid, like, probably like 12.
And I just saw it.
And it just looked at me and it said the word zone is Z-O-N-E.
And then I kind of just like said that a couple times.
that a couple times and then it just ran away.
Was it the classic almond-shaped eye
and head, tear drop head kind of thing?
It was similar to that, but not as exaggerated.
It was more like it looked like,
it just kind of looked like a weird-looking,
maybe it was a weird-looking guy.
Yeah.
It might have just been a neighbor.
Was he small?
Yeah, it was a small, weird-looking guy,
but he was kind of green and big, huge eyes.
I mean, it looked like an alien that you think about.
And when he said that,
do you feel like he was telling you, like, get it?
in the zone, like lock in, like it was encouragement, like, hey, man, get into the zone.
Study harder in school.
Yeah.
Now, all right, so then I'll half joking aside and all that, would you be surprised if
there was a mainstream declaration from the government that we have in fact, we can confirm
that this is more than a possibility and kind of get ready for this multi-year kind of trick.
rollout information to really make this legitimate and substantial.
Like they're here.
I think the impact on society, I think it would destroy society.
I think more so than like anything else because I think religion like would crumble.
Science would be gone.
Yeah.
But but like what about what somebody said last night that, you know, there's a,
What if there's a possibility, let's say,
that there's a group of wise men there in the government
that is trying to figure out the best responsible way
in which to condition the public
to this inevitable reveal.
And that, you know, Stephen Spielberg's next movie,
it's coming out at the end of this year,
is called Disclosure.
Like, it's going to be an enormous film.
And it is about, from what I can gather from the trailer,
the public finally being told.
Right.
And it's probably funded by the CIA.
I'm not even kidding.
And I'm saying maybe this group was,
they pulled Spielberg in and said,
hey, listen, could you help us out with,
could you cover the pop culture end of this?
And just start to...
We need you to feed that, like,
give the Pablam to the people so that they can kind of...
They're not so ambushed when it comes out and it's, you know...
I think people, no matter what the news is,
they'll just keep scrolling.
I mean, there could be aliens among us right now.
They'll just keep scrolling.
I think that's the conditioned, you know?
You don't think it's going to...
It won't jarred them out of it and they'll think,
no, that's probably not real.
I don't think so.
No, I think people will, like, seek out alien porn
and, like, they'll do, like, it'll be more...
Porn is always on the cutting edge of everything.
They're always first on everything.
I mean, even engagement with, you know, ghosts and stuff.
It's always porn.
Porn's always first.
But I think that this movie is probably crazy timing.
And, like, and the launch, like, I do think the CIA's,
I sound so...
I probably sound like the most insane guests you ever had.
No, no, no.
Okay, good, okay, good, okay.
We haven't aired those, but...
But I think that the CIA has been known to use, like,
movies to, like, promote, like, oh, we're going to war in the Middle East.
By the way, they would always do, you know,
the government would make film, they would decide what kinds of films should be made
at times of war, second world wars.
And to sort of, you know, garner support and get people,
lifts people's spirits and get them feeling patriotic and that's not new.
All right.
So, Mr.
Where to begin?
I mean, where to begin?
What kind of statement is over?
How do we claw back?
Start us, take us, walk us towards, you know, you're now sort of this, you know,
one of these forward voices in pop culture today.
How did it all kind of start?
Did you, was this a goal?
You started in Minneapolis, yes.
You got a journalism degree, maybe, yes.
And then a business degree?
Yeah, that was a failure.
I didn't finish that.
And then you travel out to New York in pursuit of...
Just not living in a small town.
Okay.
It was really a classic.
And it was kind of like a, like, let me go out east and, like, strike gold in the same way that, you know, there's a Silicon Valley rush and the gold rush.
And I was like, oh, I'm going to go to New York.
I'm going to get rich and famous.
And that was a long time.
That was 15 years ago.
Any industry you had focused on or is just like that town has a lot of different ones.
We'll see what hits.
At the time, I was very much into, like, entrepreneurship in this, like,
The social network had just come out.
I was like, oh, like, that's like, that was cool.
Remember for a while that was really cool?
It was really cool to be like a tech founder.
Right, right.
And I was like, oh, that's the way you do it.
And all these young people were like making so much money.
And I was like, oh, I think I should be a tech guy.
Right.
Take technology, use your creativity, your insight, your savviness,
and see where the two could intersect.
Yeah.
But really the ultimate goal was to strike it rich.
Yeah, it was definitely in pursuit of, yeah, yeah.
I was like, let's get to the...
And I did the opposite.
I did the exact opposite, because I got a job at Vice.
Yeah.
And Vice pays you, it's like they get three, they get a three-for-one deal,
so they get like three 25-year-old kids.
They pay you in cocaine.
Is that what you're going to say?
They do.
They actually do.
At least holiday bonuses for paid and cut.
I remember Christmas, it was like, here's a bag of blow.
And I was like, oh, cool, this is so cool.
This is so interesting.
Sure.
Could I pay my rent with Blow?
So your advice and you're doing marketing stuff with them, maybe, yeah?
Yeah, I'm doing like content development and marketing
and kind of like launching new shows.
And I was never the talent, but I wanted to be the talent.
Were you working with like Shane and Eddie and all those guys?
Yeah.
And at the time it was like 75 people, so we were all in the same room.
And I was listening to them on the phone.
And I'm like, whoa, this is so cool.
Like, it really was, like, getting...
That was a real MBA in business
because I'm, like, sitting in this room
with Shane and Eddie and Sirouche and all these guys.
I'm, like, listening to them.
Sirush, I love Sirush.
He's awesome.
He's such a good guy.
Like, I just saw him the other day.
He's the greatest guy.
He's so cool.
Well, from a marketing standpoint and also a content,
that was such an exciting company
and hearing about it, seeing it coming,
and getting it.
on board and kind of following it
you guys did a great job at that.
It was really cool. It was really cool. And it felt
like we were doing something like it was like... And Spike
was around a bunch there too, wasn't he?
Yeah, he was like the
executive creative director, which meant that he just
got to say that.
And he would hang out.
Like, he was just like, that's such a cool job.
David Cross was kicking around a little bit too, wasn't it?
That was early days. He wasn't there at that point.
Yeah. No, I was there in 2012.
Yeah.
And then, and from there you go to the New York Times?
Yes.
Yeah.
And for them, you did what?
Less Coke, I bet.
I did the same thing.
A lot less Coke.
A lot, a lot less Coke.
It was kind of like, that's why I quit.
Of course.
The Times was like, we just pay money.
And I was like, mm.
Yeah, you're like, well.
Money can't buy Coke.
It's Christmas, and I haven't seen my blow yet.
Did I not perform this year?
E-mailing the editor-in-chief.
I'm like, hey, dude, I'm going to quit unless I get, like, a little bonus here.
So what were you doing for, what did you do for New York Times?
I was doing the same thing.
I, like, helped start Times video, which now makes film and television and kind of the podcasting and all that stuff.
So I was, like, laying the groundwork for all that.
And it was really cool, but then I did.
So this is, like, I think I was, like, in New York for, like, maybe seven or eight years.
And at that point, I was like, okay, I know enough people.
I have enough information and knowledge and, like, maybe some access to money.
that I can actually go start my thing,
like my media company.
And that was a massive failure.
But I did do that for a couple of years.
What was that first swing and miss?
Well, there was like a couple in a row.
It was along at that.
Yeah, it was like, it was three strikes.
Those three strikes.
And then I was out.
And that's when I was like,
maybe I'm not so good at being like a CEO or an entrepreneur.
And maybe I should just be, like, do what I'm good at,
which it seems like,
hanging out, like I'm really good at hanging out.
And, like, you know, podcastings, just really, you guys are just hang out guys.
Yeah, just interviewing, having conversations.
We're hanging out, kids, for sure.
Yeah, so I was like, maybe I should try my hand to that.
But the first swing and a mess was something called NYC.tv.
And the idea was to do public access television on the internet.
Right.
Which I was like, that's a clever little something, something, something.
Yeah.
And it just didn't work.
And then I shifted that into something called Nameless Network, which was like,
do you remember like now this news
like these
they're kind of like made like
thousands of viral videos every month
that would be like
this guy is selling yams in Japan
on a street corner dressed as a cat
you never saw like videos
no
they were like short like two minute videos
and it would just be like big text on a screen
and it would be like this school
in Turkey is offering free
haircuts to young people
so just like I mean real attention
Like, grabbers.
Yeah.
I mean, stuff that's really mattering to people.
Yams in Japan, haircuts in Turkey.
I mean, and you're telling me that this did not take off.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
So then a few swings and misses.
And then you say, well, maybe I should just grab a camera and a microphone, get in front of it.
And start doing what comes natural, which is just kind of being a man of the people.
and see what comes.
So what was that first thing
that kind of grabbed
and you could feel the momentum moving
and this may be working.
The first big hill was a show
that I created.
And this is a time when there was like no shows.
Like there was no short form
unscripted vertical video shows.
And I say that.
And it was just like everyone was making content,
but there was no like show in this thing.
But I decided to make a show
and I was like, why isn't there just a TV show?
that's distributed on TikTok and Instagram,
and it was called Keep the Meter Running.
And it was this concept where I would hail a cab
and just tell the driver to take me wherever they want.
And it was always insane.
Like it would just be so crazy.
Like one time I hail the cab.
The taxi driver has it flipped on him or her
where they're not being told where to go by the person in the back,
but you get to take me, the passenger,
wherever you driver, want to go.
And just keep the meter running and tell me about why you like that.
this place. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I would just go take me
your favorite place and keep the meter running. And
I would end up, like, one time I ended
up, like, in New Jersey
on a helicopter with this guy from Morocco. And he was
literally just
getting and driving. No way. Can you drive it?
Really? Wow. But yeah, he had
a pint of Malibu, which I thought was an interesting
choice. That is an interesting choice. That is an interesting. Right, right.
It was nice. The white bottle. It's smooth.
Sure.
So you do that. So you do the keep the meter running
for a while.
Yeah, I do like 20 episodes.
And still going.
Yes, and now it's back.
The meter, well, I had to stop
because at the time it was my first thing and I was a massive failure,
remember, and I had no money.
And those episodes were, obviously,
when you tell a guy, keep the meter running and he goes,
let's go on a helicopter ride in New Jersey,
by the end of the day, you spent literally $2,000.
Sure, right, yeah, yeah, right.
And so I could only do, I spent all of my money.
Oh, my God.
And then I was like, I have to put this on pause.
And then I was like, and now it's back.
except bigger.
Now it's like YouTube,
it's like 20-minute episodes.
Sure, right.
It's crazy now.
I'm so surprised,
how do you get them to,
because I know a lot of cab drivers
that I want to,
the cabs I get in.
Oh, do you, Sean?
You know a lot of cab drivers.
They don't, no, they don't want to talk.
What?
Yeah, they don't want to.
Guys, have you experienced that?
They all want to talk.
Just not to Sean.
Oh, all right.
No.
Well, maybe I don't.
Maybe I don't talk.
They're usually on the phone,
and they want to just keep their conversation
going on their phone.
I just assume they don't want to chat.
Oh, you can't tell them to stop talking.
Especially when you get the camera going, right?
They hang up, yeah.
Maybe just bring up, like, just be like so.
How about, you know, like politics?
Medallians.
Don't bring up medallions.
No, I just figured that that's a real hot topic.
So what was the first sign that people were watching Keep the Meter running?
How did you find out?
Legitimately the next day.
So, like, I posted the video and I turned my phone off
because I was, like, another failure.
I was conditioned to just fail at that point.
When you say post it, what did you throw it up on?
I put it on TikTok and Instagram.
Okay.
Of which you had already some followers.
But not a lot, like 30,000, you know?
And so enough to like, you know.
For them to then send it out to their folks.
And that's how viral happens, right?
Oh, hang on a second.
Walk us through that, J.B.
Granddad is just...
I can't wait to hear your understanding of how this is...
Isn't it an exponential dissemination of...
I noticed you didn't say the word algorithm in that.
You actually said that the friends.
I say that for later.
Oh, yeah.
That's his closer.
It's such a great idea.
So you put it up and you turn off your phone,
you turn on your phone later that night and...
Well, I go to the bodega the next morning.
And at this point, I just turned my phone back on,
but I didn't log.
like I didn't open the apps.
I went to the bodega and the guy goes,
oh, you look so familiar.
And I go, I don't know, I'm a loser.
I've been here a million times.
Like, I've literally been here.
I look familiar because I see you every day.
Right.
And he goes, no, you look so familiar.
And then he goes,
taxi, you're the taxi guy.
You did the show.
And I was like, what?
And I opened my phone and it has like two million views.
No, wow.
In a night.
Yeah.
And so many, like, thousands of comments.
And I was like, holy shit, it actually worked.
And it felt like that moment where I was like,
I did something that for the first time ever,
people responded to it,
and it was doing exactly what I thought I could do well,
which is hang out.
And I was like, oh my God,
like maybe I'm finally found my thing.
Yeah.
You know, I called my mom.
I was like, I know what I'm going to do for a living.
I'm just going to hang out with other people.
And so you immediately tried to double down,
triple down, have another episode.
Bought a Ferrari first.
About a Ferrari that morning.
This is going to pan out.
The new episode, the new season is premiering soon.
It's the 19th, right?
May 13th, whatever that is.
May 13th, yes.
I think that's in, I think this is the 11th today.
I think it's in two days.
So what season is that?
This is like the first official season of my,
I'm bringing my thesis of making television.
and putting it on YouTube.
But, like, it's not a YouTube show
because it is television quality production
and television storytelling.
And, like, we have...
You know, I went to, like, the Russian Turkic bathhouse
with a guy named Eugene and his friend Boris.
He was on the phone.
We'll get into that later.
Let's talk about the show.
That is the show!
Oh, oh, sorry.
And, you know, do that.
I'm producing...
I produced a play for an Irish cab driver
named Irish John.
That's not his name.
but, you know, I call him that.
And he goes, I have a one-man show, and I go,
what's this all about?
So he takes me to his basement, he shows me this one-man show.
I go, cool, let's put it in a theater.
So, you know, performing in front of 300 people,
all self-produced, looks like a stand-up special,
and, you know, go fishing with a Korean guy named Young in Bear Mountain and sketch.
And just, it's really remarkable.
And the whole kind of through line of the show is, like,
how to be a better man.
Like how to be a better brother,
how to be a better father,
how to be a better friend.
It's all,
because these guys have like
the secret to the universe.
You know, like you're driving for 12 hours a day,
your life is hard,
you're sending money home,
or you're just supporting your family,
and they like have this fatherly wisdom.
I don't know if any of you guys lost your father early.
I lost mine when I was 20.
And I started like having these convos
with these cab drivers
because I felt like they had some advice.
for me.
Right.
You know,
and I didn't have
Will's number yet,
so I couldn't call him.
I couldn't call him for advice.
Sean didn't lose his dad.
His dad got lost.
Yeah.
So, wow, that's really remarkable, man.
That's so cool.
Yeah, that's really cool.
And then so then tell us about,
then subway takes happens.
You feel, you get an idea for that
and you figure you can do it at the same time simultaneously?
Well, I had.
run out of the money because the other show was costing like $2,000 per episode.
And so I was like, okay, this is this whole like short form unscripted thing is like really
working for me.
What's like another version of that which is less expensive?
And again, like...
Sorry, let me just stop you for one second.
Educate me and our listener because this might be fascinating.
It certainly would be to me.
How do you run out of money doing that show?
Because I guess the question is, how do you monetize a show?
show like that. So you put it up on Instagram and TikTok. How are you even thinking you could get
paid for that? How does a creator get paid for that? Can you advertise against those little short form?
Yeah, like the guy made you see, he sees your first episode. It's got two million views overnight.
Are you seeing that in real time in dollars coming to you? No, I'm seeing zero dollars.
That's the problem. That's my question. How would you even hope to monetize that? How would you get paid for that?
You would want, like, a brand to essentially say,
I love what you're doing.
Hey, do you want to pay in every episode,
do you want to use your Chase debit card or credit card
to pay for the cabbies bill?
Or do you want to communicate using WhatsApp exclusively
with, like, their families and your friends, and blah, blah?
So you'd want someone to underwrite the series.
In the same way that, like, a streamer or a production company
or a network would underwrite, it's brand-funded entertainment.
So you were pursuing that and getting no bites?
So you just didn't know to do that yet.
I didn't know to do that yet.
And I also was, like, so overwhelmed and just kind of, I was in panic mode.
Like, I don't know what to do with this.
You know, I don't.
And actually, the first thing I did was like, I was like, okay, maybe this should be a TV show instead.
And, like, I should get money from someone in Hollywood.
Right.
And, but that whole rigamarole.
Yeah.
I went on, like, a wild goose chase with that.
I was like, I don't know.
This is, yeah, it was taking too long.
And in the meantime, I was like, let me start another thing.
while this is baking in the TV world,
let me start another thing to kind of like continue my work.
But what made you think that second thing
would be something that you would be able to monetize
and get money out of?
I didn't really think about that either.
It was really more so like, like this is making.
I'm really noticing a trend here.
Yeah.
You thought, I'm not making any money with the thing.
This thing's costing me money.
What I should do is interview Jason Bateman on the subway,
holding a metric card instead of a microphone.
That'll do it.
It worked.
I'm here.
It did.
I loved J.B.
I loved your episode.
I thought you were going on.
Oh, man, I did too.
What a fun time I had that.
If you guys have not seen Subway Takes,
and I haven't seen Keep the Meter running yet.
I can't wait to watch that.
I know me too.
Oh, I need both of you guys on there.
Tell people what Subway Takes what the concept of that is.
So Subway Takes is essentially like a two-minute talk show on the train
where I interview like local stand-up comedians,
regular comedians, musicians, writers, directors,
like anyone who I find kind of interesting
and also people like Jason Bateman.
Right, so then you, and then you had Jason on.
Yeah, we got to balance it out.
It must have...
You can't appreciate the big ones
unless you get a couple of clunkers.
I found him kind of interesting.
I was just like he's kind of interesting.
You know what I mean?
It's an interesting.
I'm curious about the details of your episode with J.B.
Well, okay, concept,
But I really want to know what station did you guys get in?
Yeah, what did you guys do?
What train were you on and where did you get?
We were lower east side.
Yes, we were in Chinatown on the F train at East Broadway.
Wow.
Yes, I remember.
I had to boil my entire body after that.
And Jason, I mean, what was, Jason, the look on your driver's face when you said, take me there.
He said, let you out here.
I said, no, no, no, hang on.
Just keep the door close for a minute.
Jason brought an extra pair of pants.
hands and an extra shirt.
And some plastic to sit on.
He called it his train clothes.
That's what he called his train clothes.
And he was wearing white latex gloves.
And I was like, why are you wearing those?
That sounds right.
I love the train.
I'm in the Metro card.
So you go, you decide, all right.
But the concept is, listener, is that he has somebody come on and just give one hot take on something.
Right.
And Kareem decides whether he's 100.
percent on board with that or in opposition to that.
For instance, my dumbass hot take was I think all dogs should wear shoes.
100% agree.
But then the interview is, well, why do you agree and why do I think they're doing it?
Basically, you know, I just think, you know, so that they, you know, you don't want them to walk into your place and track in all the poo they like to walk around in.
Yeah.
So anyway.
But so that's kind of the concept.
and it's a two-minute concept
and it's pleasurable
and we're popping around the city
and...
You think dogs, if dogs go to a play
they should go backstage.
And see the artists.
Sorry, we'll go to that later.
But Kareem, can we do a hot take to you?
Like, because I just thought of this
when you popped on about that show
and I was like, doing Broadway shows,
you know those rickshaws
that are super fucking loud?
Yeah.
At night?
Yeah, yeah.
Like, shouldn't there be a law against the sound of those?
100% agree.
Yeah, there's too much noise pollution in New York City.
Oh, Sean, is this our segment called Old Man Gripes?
What are we doing?
Yeah.
And shouldn't those damn kids slow down in the neighborhood?
No, he's right.
It's too damn loud.
I agree.
You're so synonymous with New York.
I just thought, you know, what do you think about?
Like, because I don't have any skin in the game with Mom Dani.
I don't know if he's good or bad or anything.
I don't live, you know, I'm just here part-time working.
But somebody complained that it's because of Mom Dane
that the snow banks weren't clear.
I'm like, the snow.
When there's a blizzard, there's never, you can't clear all the snow.
Yeah, where do you want them to put it?
Yeah.
Well, you got to, being the mayor of New York is the worst job in America.
Because everyone's just mad at you no matter what you do.
Right, for sure.
For sure.
It's a historical, big L.
I would never do it, although I might.
Have you ever had somebody that...
Uh-oh.
Have you ever had somebody...
Talk about breaking fucking...
I would only do it as a joke,
and then I would accidentally win, like, you know who, our boy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, whoopsies, I'm the mirror now.
Just trying to sell a book.
What, has anybody come on and not had a take,
and then you had to say, all right, well, I'll do one.
Well, didn't you go through the vetting process, Jason?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, I was given a heads up, but, you know, I'm a professional.
I can't prepare.
Sure, see if I can pull up some of it.
if some of these people come on and just like,
yeah, I couldn't think of anything.
Should I see if Jason Bateman had any other ones
that we didn't use? Yeah.
Oh, did I pitch you some?
I don't know. Let me check my email.
So they go to someone on my team.
Yeah.
And then I don't, there's like somebody approves
that they're good.
Right.
And then, and then.
Like just some Gen Z kid?
Yeah, pretty literally.
Literally a young, young lads.
Which, what's the last one you disagreed with?
Oh, dude, I don't know.
I don't know.
You're doing one, what are you doing?
One a week?
No, we post one a day.
No.
What?
I post one a day.
Yeah, it's my soul.
So then you're doing one a day to keep up with the output?
No, I batch, I shoot, I'll shoot like 10 in one day.
No way.
It's really a miserable day.
I'm like a real working, you know, blue-collar guy.
I'm underground all day.
I'm sweating, or it's too cold, or it's too hot,
or the train's not working, or somebody's trying to stab me,
from walker.
Yeah, it's really tough.
Don't you find that,
am I just an introvert?
A little lunch pal guy over here.
Am I just an introvert that needs to refill my talk tank a lot?
Or does everybody go through sort of like a social exhaustion like me sometimes?
Like, how do you not run out of being, you know, chatty?
By doing 10 episodes in a day, how do you keep it going like that?
Will's raising us out.
Well, I've got a thought on this, which is,
Which is always, you know, when you go and you do interviews and stuff
doing what we do and you have to go on talk shows.
And when I realize that I don't have stuff to talk about it's because I haven't been out in the world.
And so a lot of people we know, including us or whatever,
spend these times in this world.
And we're not out in bubbles and you're not engaged in a real way.
And about 50 years ago.
I would say, like, I want to experience life.
And that's why I'm always on the move and doing, I swear to God.
I know how boring that's a piece.
break so you're out there walking around with your
fucking hands tucked in your pockets
just like squinting around
one hand how have a fucking
just soaking it all in hey good morning
man how you doing have a good day
no I'm serious
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
I'm more down to earth
or anything what I'm saying is that I realize
you have to get out there
Sean and I have talked about this
a number of times
and Jason you're a lost cause because you're at home or in the golf
course and so like that's okay
How the fuck would you have anything to talk about?
I could fill you in on what MS Now's new programming strategies are.
No, but it is true.
I think that there is something to that, right?
Just being engaged.
I don't care who you are, just being engaged in the world.
Having stuff to say.
I get it.
Yeah.
Is that true?
Karim, is that your fuel?
No, I mean, I'm having fun.
Like, I really am having a lot of fun.
I have such a fun job.
Both of my jobs.
You're great at it.
hanging out with cab drivers, hanging out with people like you guys.
Like, it is the, I'm blessed as a person.
Like, I have the best job in the world.
And everything that I've done thus far has been totally independent.
So I really have no notes.
I have no development.
I'm just doing the fun part of the job, which is the making of it.
And that's all I do.
And it's really amazing.
And I have a lot of energy.
That's how we feel.
Amen.
What would five years from now look like if it continued on this,
on this angle of success.
What is your, what's your, what's your hope for where things go with this?
Like, well, go ahead.
I really don't know.
I mean, I'm kind of just playing about here.
Oriette Express.
Just upgrading the train line.
Or gondolas, yachts, you know, Leo DiCaprio's yacht,
I could just have a permanent spot on there.
That would be pretty good.
That could be fun.
You just talked to him for 10 episodes.
Yeah.
I could.
Yeah, that would be good.
Well, no, I talk to his wonderful guests.
I'm sure you guys have been on his yacht.
I'm not.
But like...
But I imagine, yeah, kind of going to, Jay, what you were saying,
which is like you do have...
I love that you did identify.
What you term as hanging out is actually engaging with people and talking...
Yes, and being curious.
And that's what you're good at and you're curious.
And you do have a point of view on a lot of stuff,
which is great and interesting.
And so I guess the next...
The evolution of that is...
taking that and going
and you talk to cab drivers and doing
the thing, take me where you want to go, and then talking to people
in the subway, and then would it be
kind of going broader, going around the world,
engaging with people in different
cultures? I mean, I imagine
you'd be really good at that. Exposing all of us
to other parts of the world and other
cultures of people. Yeah, that's a great idea.
We need that. But you know, keep
the meter running feels like a Bordane-esque, like people have said,
this reminds me a Bordane. And subway
it reminds a lot of people of a talk
show like Fallon or Seth Myers or whatever.
So like I kind of get to play in both worlds
and that's really cool. We're doing a live show
for Subway Takes Live which is really fun
and interesting to me.
How would that work?
People come and do what you did except
it's like it's like the audience
is giving the takes and then there's like a panel.
It would be us four on stage and people
would walk up to a mic and say
I think this and then we would all go
no you're you're an idiot blah blah blah blah
That's a great idea, yeah.
Have there ever been,
have there under been some dust-ups there on the train?
Because I remember, you know, we were just,
we were riding on,
we didn't have a shooting permit or anything like that.
We were just on the train.
Cameras were rolling a couple of cameras,
and these, you know, two guys holding these weird mics and talking,
and somebody might be recognizable.
And have you ever had, like, a weird subway passenger,
like, bother you and your guest?
Not with anyone, like, with anyone famous,
it's always, it's always a pleasure to,
see. Like Woody Harrelson was literally kind of took over the train car and he started interviewing
other people and there were all these people like, and he was just surrounded by people and just
putting this mic in their faces and asking them questions and really creating a circus like in the
car and everyone loved him. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. The timing of
that concept and you and doing all of this is really great because we're at an apex of
like people wanting to connect again.
And so it's probably probably has a lot to do with that.
And the lost art of conversation too.
I mean, everyone's kind of getting all their itches scratched just online and with
their own little devices.
In five second increments.
Yeah, they're not talking to people.
And that's why I always think that the 100% agree, 100% disagree, like there's no middle
for me.
And it is really kind of like an exploration of what it means to,
100% disagree, but still have a funny, casual, engaging conversation.
Like, I personally don't really have that many opinions.
Like, I'm pretty mellow.
But in the show, it's like, it's a challenge for me to be like, well, here's why I disagree.
But it's kind of a showcase that you can, yeah, like, have fun doing this.
But there was one funny thing.
It was like a regular episode that I was filming.
And there was a passenger on the train filming us film, which is completely,
fine, like great.
This other guy in the train
slapped the phone out of
that guy's hand and then
kicked it across the car
all the way to the other side.
And then that guy that got
his phone slapped out of his hand looks at me
and he's like, I'm so sorry, dude. And I'm like,
why? And he's like, your bouncer
just kicked the phone out of my hand. And I was
like, that's not my bouncer.
That's just a crazy guy.
For some reason, decided
that you shouldn't film me.
And there was like this confusion where everyone was kind of pointing each other.
Like, whose bodyguard is that?
Or like, do you guys know each other?
No one knew each other.
It was really funny and, like, confusing.
But that's the closest call.
Did the guy who slapped it, did he ever explain his position as to why he did it?
No, he would just yell something about like Jesus and walked away.
Oh, that makes sense.
That tracks.
So, wait, but I wanted to ask Will.
Will and Sean, what were your take?
Like, if you were on the show and I said, what's your take?
would your take be? Well, we know Sean's. Something about Rickshaws. Oh, yeah. Sean said the Rickshaw.
Willie, what's, what's about New York? Like, no, no, like I, I, one of my, one of mine is that I think
that the dancing part of the wedding is the worst part. Like, it should just, I didn't even do it.
It should be dinner. At my own wedding. I did, I didn't dance with my wife on our own wedding,
because I hate dancing so much. I didn't know that. I don't know that. Is that true? Yeah, I, I, I,
that's how much. At that moment, it's not about you. I'm so uncomfortable, dancing. I don't, I
I know it, but I just, I told her early on.
That is profoundly unkind.
I know, but I just, I couldn't, I couldn't do it.
I'm calling Amanda.
I'm calling Amanda today, and I'm going to take her out dancing.
Yeah, go, go for it.
I encourage it.
Go for it.
Please.
I encourage it.
That's so, that, that's, that's, that's a hard line.
But I was saying not at your own wedding, Jason.
I'm saying like, if you, like, it should just end at dinner.
Like, you just go have a great night, everyone.
Thanks for calling the wedding.
I 100% agree with that.
And then it's always a force thing.
The DJ is playing like Little John and the East Side Boys from like 2002.
And you're like,
and no one wants to be there.
And yeah.
So that's like,
or like I have another one,
which is that I think,
and this one I think will be problematic.
But like,
I don't like street art and graffiti.
And I would rather just look at like nice,
beautiful buildings.
Okay.
Yeah,
but a lot of people are going to get mad at me for that.
What?
Really?
People are.
Yeah.
Great defenders of graffiti?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Street art graffiti.
Aside from the people that actually do it,
you're saying people that just observe it are big fans of it?
I think so.
I think that there's a cohort of people that think that it's like, it's nice, yeah.
I enjoy it, yeah.
See?
I have too many, but all of mine get me in trouble.
All of mine are terrible.
First of all, I think I should be deputized to be able to give out,
just to the parking part of the police department.
I'd love to give out.
Oh, you would love to give a ticket.
I'd love to give out tickets and also moving vehicle tickets.
That's a good idea of citizens.
And I also think that we should be able to report when like, you know, like when like the cops who do a great job,
but when they pull people over and then they obstruct traffic and it's unnecessary.
Yeah, they don't need to hang out into the other lane.
I mean, I guess they're doing that to protect themselves as they're up at the window.
But why don't you go around to the passenger window and then you don't have to hang out in the traffic.
I don't even mean on a freeway or anything.
I mean, like, you're in New York.
You know, you're in New York, but although I'm, so I don't want to criticize NYPD because I do, I do, it's a rough, tough job.
It would be nice if they deputized us to give out maybe three citizen tickets for moving violations a month, you know, so you can't abuse it.
You just get three.
So the three most egregious things you see when you're driving, you're allowed to put the little cojack light on on top of your car and go get them.
I think it would be nice if you could also get Sean's, like if Sean wanted to ticket the loud.
rickshaw guys.
Yeah.
You could give,
like,
we should all be active,
citizen.
Like, why don't we have a little bit of power?
We're taping people anyway.
We might as well be able to use it to...
But then I thought about,
here's the flip of it.
I was thinking about this yesterday.
And then I'm like,
how many yellows have I squeezed
while driving through an intersection?
I'm like, and I'm not immune from it myself.
And so then I kind of walked it back.
But I have, God, I have so many takes on shit.
I do.
Wait, there's two that I just don't have.
One is, I don't know if this is a fake post
on Instagram or not,
but I read that New York.
is looking into making a law,
looking into making it a law
to traffic the sidewalks
like they do the streets
so that fast people walkers
walk on the left,
which I think is really a great idea.
Oh, especially in New York, it's a bummer
when people stop in the middle of the street
and you're like, hey man, and also watching their phone.
Or people walk four wide on a sidewalks.
You can't get around people.
Like, if you're a group of more than two,
you have to go kind of two by two,
kind of single-fime.
Here's my hot say.
Here's what I think.
If you want to post anything on the internet, comment, whatever, anything, we have to know your name.
And your face.
Your address, your phone number.
No anonymous.
No anonymous anymore.
And I think that that would, I think it would change the world immediately.
Immediately.
I have to.
If everybody, you have to, there is a record.
And we know that they can do it because, you know, things like the blockchain where you can trace absolutely everything where you know.
So if we applied that same logic to that.
So you can't go on to anything, you can't make any comment.
You can, but we know your name, your address, your phone number.
And by that we'll be able to decipher where you work, who your family is, all that sort of stuff.
And you are held, so that because if I make a comment, everybody knows who I am.
And so then I get held up to this crazy high standard that everybody else has not held up to.
Yeah.
But wait, here's my other take is Jason commented on me the other night.
when we were at dinner, that when you order a dessert for yourself,
and then the waitress comes over with spoons for everybody at the table,
and you're like, wait, no, everybody passed on ordering dessert.
I ordered dessert, and when offered, everybody else's like,
no, I'm good, I don't want a dessert.
And then everybody spoons the shit out of your fucking dessert.
Good take.
I'm like, no, get your own dessert.
Right.
Like, I did.
If you did not opt in, you don't get a spoon.
Unless it was specified, bring us the Sunday.
and bring everybody a spoon.
That's right.
Otherwise, no.
Don't do this spoon.
Shout out to Odeon.
Remember we had that,
so we did have that the other night at the Odeon.
Right.
And I would,
and I ordered this,
I started because I said,
I want to get a Sunday.
And it was like, ooh,
and I go,
everybody gets your own dessert.
You're not for fucking.
That's right.
You almost have to announce it this week.
You have to announce it.
Oh, that's so funny.
Yeah.
And Jason, Jason was like,
don't get the donuts.
I got two orders of donuts.
He fucking, his face was buried in both.
You did bless you.
I had six of them.
Now, Kareem, with all of this really cool, very well-deserved success,
what has changed in your, I'm presuming, very sort of down-to-earth, man-of-the-people life?
Have you, Will joked earlier that you...
Like, upgraded your air conditioner?
Right.
Or is it still tape to the window and red tape?
Look at that.
Don't worry about it.
Well, that's another big take that I have when I was installing this.
I was like, it is shocking that they let me do this in New York.
And if I'm taping mine, that means that there, and then I started looking around,
there's like people that their air conditioners are being held up by books.
Some people have a little piece of wood.
And I'm like, there's not a standard processing.
I agree.
Yeah, there's a guy over there that has a couple of textbook.
I can see.
I'm like, and it's so scary because now I can't walk around New York City without thinking about my own self
putting in my air conditioner,
and you guys obviously see how good of a job I've done.
I know.
I remember Kreme,
the first time I put an air conditioner in my window in New York
and thinking, this is freaking lunacy.
This can go at any time.
I just did this.
I'm an idiot,
and this thing is going to fall on somebody and kill somebody.
And it's not like the windows are nice.
The windows are flimsy.
The windows are flimsy windows.
They're made out of saran wrap, essentially.
And it's just terrifying.
and there's no screws.
None of this, there's no tools.
No.
This is just like the windows holding in the place.
So you haven't,
so you haven't gone to mainstream air conditioning.
What, what have you treated yourself to?
I mean, I, there's a lot less anxiety in my life
about what I'm supposed to be doing for a living.
And that is really scary because I also started doing this when I was 33,
which is later than many people,
like many comedians or these social media kids.
You know, they start when they're like 22,
who 21, 25.
They were in their college
improv group.
So to start at 33
and take like this massive bet
and then have it work out,
it's shocking.
And every day I'm just like...
It's dope.
It's not shocking.
You're a smart guy
and you are really funny.
And I...
Do you refer to yourself
as when people say,
what do you...
You don't say creator, do you?
No, no, no.
I say entertainer.
Because I also made...
I wrote a movie,
produced it, starred in it.
That's out on movie.
I make music.
What's that called?
I'm in a rock and roll band.
The movie's called Or Something.
Or something.
And it's a feature film.
It's my first feature.
And we can find that where?
On Mooby, M-U-B-I.
M-U-B-I.
Okay.
That's like T-B-B-B-W-A.
Do I have M-B-E-B-B-E?
And then you say, you're in a band, too?
No.
Yeah, I'm in a rock-and-roll band called Tiny Gun.
That's amazing.
Are you singing?
Are you drumming?
Are you guitaring?
I sing.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
And it's kind of like a punk, like, Pixies.
We love pixies.
The pixies meets the strokes kind of situation.
Yeah, that's cool.
Speaking my language.
Yeah, give us a listen.
Tiny gun.
Tondi.
Hondo P.
We played outside land.
Last year we played outside lands
in Newport Folk Festival.
It was really fun.
Yeah.
Do you guys hear those sirens?
Yeah, it's hard not to.
Yeah, they can excite the air conditioner.
Well, yeah, that's a ticket.
It's Sean.
It's Will and Sean.
Sean on this Rickshaw.
It's Jason Bateman on his motorcycle.
I'm so, honestly, I'm so inspired by how much different stuff you do
and how many creative swings you take at once.
I think it's awesome.
I think that that is, you're doing the very thing that I was talking about,
that I wish I could do more.
You're taking chances and you're engaging in life in such an awesome way.
I think it's dope as hell.
There's some cultural relevance and help to it as well, right?
It's amazing.
It's really cool.
You guys are, that feels like it's such a compliment coming from you guys.
No, but you're not catering to the lowest common.
And like you're trying to do stuff that,
not necessarily sort of worthy in the sense of, like, you know, helping humanity.
But you are in a way, you are sort of engaging and keeping conversation going
and provoking thought and just, I don't know, I think it's really rad.
Bringing folks together.
It's just that classic playing at the top of your intelligence situation,
which I feel like because so many people are not doing that,
I was like, let me just be a little bit different
and try to be the smartest version.
of what this thing limits you to,
which is a phone, tiny screen,
vertical, like, let me try to do the smartest thing possible.
And you're not prancing around in a speedo.
You know what I mean?
Trying to see...
You don't want to see me in a speedo.
Wait, where do I find that?
And selfishly, you're giving us ding-dongs
that are like promoting stuff
this really great, fun, creative stop
on our press tours to go talk to folks.
Yeah, I want to have you guys on.
I want to come to...
I want to do...
I would have all three of you on at the same time.
Oh, that would be lit.
But here's the thing.
Jason did it.
I want to do just to one-up him, obviously.
Of course.
Double up.
Double app.
Four minutes.
No, let's get you out.
Let's get you next time you're in New York.
I'm there.
I'll be there.
I'll be there half the time.
Great.
Then I will do it at literally any time.
Like, I'll step out of the house, you know.
Can we take the one-nine?
Is that okay?
Yeah, I was going to say, what would be your subway?
What the hell's that?
You know, like, what do they call it?
The one now?
It used to be the one-nine on the west side, you know, the red line.
Oh, I've never been over there.
Really?
I'm an east side guy.
We can do the east side too.
It's like, no, no, no, no, I'll come to you.
I'll come to you.
No, we'll take the six.
That's fine.
No, no, no, no, come to you.
But fuck it, I'll take the F.
I don't give you shit.
Wait, I also want to say something that, so I, this has nothing to do with what we're talking about,
although it kind of does, but like, going back, I don't want to tout my own horn,
to my own horn, toot my own flute.
I don't want to tut my own flute.
But I want to say this here in case anyone from the Emmy, what are they called, the Academy?
Sure.
Yeah, we're going.
Subway Takes is going for an Emmy.
Is it?
Okay.
So for your consideration, for your consideration,
Great.
Subway takes.
But wait, but does it got to be on the telly then?
I love that.
I love that you just said that.
No, they have little ones now.
Tiny Emmys?
Tiny Emmys for your boy.
Isn't that called a Webby?
No, it's a creative, the creative arts Emmy.
You can get a creative arts Emmy for like short form.
Yeah, like, you know, this a bit's a lot?
Like, like, like, like, carpool karaoke, right.
Or the dude with the hot wings?
Yes, Sean Evans from Hot Ones.
So, okay, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, Creme, to be clear, if you, if you happen to be
listening to this and you are a voter in the Television Academy,
check out consider.
Please check out Creme's show.
and consider.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
And then you're tiny,
tiny gun to listen to.
Guys,
I'm still out here doing this.
I'm still out here shilling for myself.
I mean, I love it.
No one else is going to do it.
Good for you.
I have this opportunity.
Let me,
let me,
I want to see you guys there,
first of all.
And when we see each other there,
we should hug.
Oh, at the Emmys.
Yeah.
Oh, if we're at the Emmys,
we're going to hug like hell.
Yeah.
Yep.
That's all hot.
That's a phrase, right?
Hug.
I want to like you like hell.
I want a hug like hell.
That was a really good take about men
is that we haven't standardized our creeding.
So, like, I might go up to Will with a hand up in the air,
like, what's good, man, I get to see you?
I might extend a hand to Jason,
and then he's, and it's confusing or a hug Sean.
And it's, yeah, and it's really confusing.
We need a standard.
My buddy years ago, Ali Farnakian used to say,
you always start road to the White House,
which is just a handshake,
and then anywhere you want to go after that.
But you always start Road to the White House.
This is good advice.
So you extend the hand.
Always extend the hand.
This is called Road to the White House.
Be open to getting pulled in.
And then wherever you want.
Okay.
I always love that.
You should consider driving a cab.
That's a really good cab.
Like that's kind of cab driver advice that I guess.
Hey, man, it might get to that.
Kareem, we are thrilled to have you.
We love you.
We root for you.
We're watching you.
Keep it going, my friend.
Thank you guys so much.
This was really, really fun.
and I appreciate you guys letting me be on your show.
Seriously.
We'll see you.
We'll see you that there in the city.
We'll see you on the show.
I'll see you on the show.
I can't wait for it.
Thanks, Kareem.
Okay, bye, guys.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Thanks out.
Thank you so much for having me.
You got it.
Shaking your hand, goodbye.
Digital shake.
There he goes.
Kareem.
Rama.
He's good.
He's so good.
Kareem Rama, yeah.
Really great, dude.
Shani, did you invite you on the show?
Yeah, I noticed that right there at the end.
You know, I was thinking.
I think he's worried about your safety.
I think that that was that.
By the way, I've never rode on the subway.
Hang on a second.
So maybe that's...
I'm trying to do my...
I can't believe that face.
I'm trying to...
Hang on.
Sean, that's true, isn't it?
That is very true, yeah.
Is that really true?
Never once on the subway in New York City.
I mean, if I did, maybe once 25 years ago, but I don't remember it.
It's not on purpose.
It just hasn't happened.
I just don't feel...
I'd just rather take a cap.
Oh, so it is on purpose?
Yeah, yeah, it's totally on purpose.
I don't even know how they work.
I don't even remember where they are.
There is so...
I will give you...
It is a hack
because you spend a lot more time
in New York these days.
If you have to...
You get anywhere in like two seconds.
But now it works with your navigation app,
like Waze or Google Maps
or Apple Mets or whatever it is,
you can just say, you know,
how do I get there via walking,
via car, or via subway?
And then when you hit the subway thing,
it'll give you a little map
how to walk to the subway, what to do?
But it's overwhelming to me
because there's...
Aren't there like 75,000...
But it tells you with...
It'll walk you.
Yeah, it'll tell you what to do.
If you don't know it, it'll tell you what to do.
And I'm telling you, you can save yourself hours of being stuck in a freaking car or a cat.
It's so good.
And it's so safe.
Like what?
All right.
Well, that's a little bit of that too, yeah.
It is great.
All right.
We'll do it together because I love riding on them.
We'll do it next time I'm there.
All right.
We'll hold hands all the way through it.
But you guys should check out those two shows.
Very good.
Yeah, I will.
I've seen a couple of his clips on, on Instagram.
And they're always funny and engaging.
So funny.
Like, like you see.
said Jason, it's really interesting that he started, well, you both said it, that he started
something out of like, you know, who would have thought that just conversation would be
interesting to people, you know, like, well, I will say this, I think that there probably
are, Sean, a lot of people who think, like, hey, I'm interesting and I could just do, I'm going
to do a talk show or I'm going to do a thing. And the truth was that he did have an actual
a talent for it and that he is an engaging person. And he's very authentic and real.
Very authentic.
Yeah, you know exactly.
That's the key.
Yeah, you just know who he is.
Yeah.
And I bet he could do it.
He could probably take it on the road.
He could go overseas.
He could do it.
He could definitely do one in Egypt because he was born in Egypt.
So I'd assume that he is by.
Lingwool.
Very good.
Bye.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic.
And artisanly handcraft.
by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
Smart. Less.